Ukraine's president has called an
emergency meeting after a major dam was
blown up the Nova kokova Dam sits on the
dinipra river in the Harrison region
which Russia controls Ukraine's military
blames Russia but Moscow pointed
officials say it was destroyed by
shelling evacuations of surrounding
areas are now underway the zaparita
nuclear power plant further down the
river is said to be in no danger but
Charles Stratford joins us live now from
the Ukrainian Capital at Charles so what
more can you tell us about this dam
being breached
well a huge significance as you can
imagine Darren this Dam
um analysts have long pointed at it as
being a potential Target to be blown up
by both sides in fact because
the ukrainians could well be
um interested in in seeing this down
blown up because it is so important in
terms of supplying water and irrigation
to Russian occupied Crimea and of course
the Russians would see it as potentially
being a weapon as a means of making it
more difficult for Ukrainian forces to
cross the Juniper River into Russian
occupied Crimea in any kind of ground
offensive the latest we're hearing
certainly from the Ukrainian government
we understand that president zielinski
is going to be holding an emergency
meeting with the state the National
Security Council we're also hearing from
the ukrainians that they believe that
critical water levels will reach um will
reach a critical point around five hours
from now and we also know that there are
ongoing evacuations
from some of the settlements that are
going to be affected certainly um Tas
the Russian news agency are saying that
there are around 80 settlements that
could be affected and there are
evacuations going on from there we
understand but that's on their side of
the river that's on the southern side
there are a whole host of other
settlements on the North as well of
course this area has seen some pretty
heavy fighting less so in recent months
since the Ukrainian forces pushed the
Russian forces out of kerasan but we
still know that there are a lot of
people that live in this area
we also know that it has been reported
and not denied by Ukrainian military
that
um there have been sort of Special
Forces it's understood Ukrainian Special
Forces certainly Ukrainian troops where
about a month ago reported to have
crossed that area of the river further
south from the dam and had taken up
positions
um south of the river so if indeed this
was the Russians and that's what the
ukrainians are saying then this is one
can only imagine a bid to wipe that area
out and as I say make it far more
difficult for you Cranium forces to push
further forward okay I mean this is a
large body of water and that's that's an
understatement I mean this damage three
meters high 3.2 kilometers long supplies
hydroelectric power to the whole region
so it is of huge significance and of
great concern obviously as you can
imagine for the civilians still living
in that area yeah Charlie a claim and
counterclaim as well over Ukraine's
offensives in Don yes what else has been
happening
foreign
as you say
um we've heard over the last sort of 48
hours or so an intensification of
fighting in various locations around uh
Donetsk the Donetsk region and further
south of that
um the ukrainians claiming that they
have made inroads to the south of the uh
the the the Russian captured town of
bakmut that was taking control of by the
Russian forces after months and months
of fighting last month now the
ukrainian's saying that they have
recaptured some areas to the south of
that we're also hearing reports of
ongoing fighting
um in areas of Southern Donetsk region
the Russians saying that they repelled
an attack by Ukrainian forces yesterday
we understand that this fighting is
ongoing we've been looking at some of
these developments and whether this
actually
represents finally the uh the beginnings
of this long-awaited Ukrainian
counter-offensive and this is our report
the Russian army says this video shows
Ukrainian military vehicles being forced
to withdraw after a failed attempt to
push into russian-occupied territory in
the southern Donetsk region of eastern
Ukraine
on June the 4th the enemy launched an
unsuccessful attempt at a large-scale
offensive in the South donett's
Direction six mechanized and two tank
battalions of the enemy were activated
their goal was to break through our
defenses in the most vulnerable in their
opinion sectors of the front the enemy
did not achieve its tasks it had no
successes
the statement which is difficult to
independently verify comes a few days
after Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski said his armed forces were now
ready for a long-awaited Ukrainian
counter-offensive his foreign minister
implied the same we received enough
weapons to begin the counter-offensive
but I will say again my answer is it's
always the same to this
I will say that we received enough of
weapons
after we win
because until
we haven't won
there is there will be Never Enough of
weapons
the Ukrainian military says this video
shows Russian positions coming under
heavy fire to the south of the town of
bahut which Russia claimed full control
of last month
I was later the leader of the Russian
mercenary group Wagner released an audio
message saying Ukrainian forces were
making small gains in the village of
berkiefka north of the town yet again
blamed Russian defense minister Sergey
shoigu and chief of general staff Valeri
kerosimov
Ka has already been lost the troops are
quietly running away what a disgrace
shoigu gerasimov I urge you go to the
front line pick up a gun and make the
troops stand up and move forward come on
you can do it and if not you will die
Heroes
the Ukrainian military in recent days
has launched what can be described as a
campaign of Silence
it released this video aimed at the
public the media and Ukrainian soldiers
appealing for silence on the
counter-offensive in order to preserve
some element of surprise
and with the claim and counter claims
there is increasing evidence of an
intensification of fighting at various
locations along the front line whether
this represents the beginning of the
long-awaited Ukrainian counter-offensive
and efforts by Ukrainian forces to find
weak spots in Russian defense or indeed
these are small probing attacks ahead of
a larger full-scale operation
well that will become clear in the
coming days Charles Strafford Al Jazeera
Keith